what's up guys I'm Lucy once more and
we're here at Star Wars Celebration 2016
to play a little bit of Star Wars
Battlefront a brand new mode called
skirmish yep it's an offline mode so
it's pretty much what everyone's been
asking for for ages but it's not quite
probably what they want
it's just took two modes that already
exist the Walker assault and The Fighter
Squadron except now you can play it with
AI let's talk a little about the AI we
played all the modes to play them
split-screen we played them and go off
to play them by yourselves
the AI is it's functional so it's very
objective driven you'll always find AI
like scrambling all of the objective and
it just keep the game moving but I found
in particular like when they weren't
doing that they were about as useful as
a chocolate teapot because there's this
points where they'll just line up and
just stand still
yeah so they lucky said they seem to
like the AI i dice unfairly built the AI
they just keep pushing them out match
board and if you've played a battlefield
game which is also another game from
dice and been in a multiplayer match
where nobody's actually following the
objective they're just killing each
other you get that same kind of vibe or
it's going on a bit too long and it
seems to be dragging out so I think they
focused on making sure the AI is always
going to capture points taking over and
then when the Walker appears to assault
it all kind of you know keeping you a
support if you run up against any
enemies on the build nine times out of
ten you will kill them because they
probably yeah they won't they barely
will chew at you they might shuffle to
the left or the right to try and avoid
some I mean there was one game when you
got a hundred West Hills yeah my final
match I got a hundred and four kills and
that was pretty much because they were
just running towards me and just staring
at me the entire time
so yeah not the most challenging but I'm
really not sure who it's for I think it
will get it launched when the main game
launched it would have been a great
precursor I'd like to prepare people for
and I multiplayer but I think what you
really lose when you're playing skirmish
is this fun random moments that you get
with playing people online you don't get
like skillful players you don't get
people
you wouldn't get like a Luke Skywalker
or one of the hero characters coming out
unless you did it and you know it's part
of the fun right you're like layers on
the field you got to take her out Oh a
lot of what made battlefront good to
play it's not a terribly deep game it's
very simple its base level my player
shooting but what made it fun is when
you group up with some you know friends
and kind of work together to push
objectives it's a very like simple type
of kind of experience movie experience
without that it's kind of empty it feels
a bit like you're wandering around the
field on your own not really doing much
and like you said you don't have these
amazing moments you know where x-wings
are coming in or layers jumping you know
Darth Vader pairs because there's no one
else to kind of make that happen that
isn't you and if it's just you doing it
every time it gets a bit boring off for
a while can you shoot him but you know
there are more DLC coming out later this
year so we've got Death Star coming out
but if you find the giving scammer go
you can download it today July 20th and
of course we know we've got battlefront
2 coming so get excited about maybe
maybe the offline mode will be a part of
a frontier launch hopefully and
but the Markos on Star Wars and
Battlefront make sure you stay tuned to
games waka
another rebel pays the price